though with new long-delayed guidelines
from the cdc
for schools and businesses looking to
reopen during this pandemic
now this comes as president trump
continues to feud
with some of his own experts he and his
chief of staff were the only people not
wearing masks yesterday
during a visit to a medical supply
facility in pennsylvania
meanwhile a whistleblower is alleging a
dangerous lack of leadership
in the federal coronavirus response dr
rick bright testified he believes the
government's actions
put millions of americans at risk
including medical workers
he says if nothing changes the worst may
be yet to come
we jejang reports from the white house
our window of opportunity is closing dr
rick bright issued a stark warning if
the administration doesn't step up its
response to covet 19.
2020 could be the darkest winter in
modern history
breit told lawmakers the federal
government's response has already failed
to protect
some americans lives are endangered and
i believe lives were lost
and he said early signs of drug and gear
shortages were ignored
i'll never forget the emails i received
from mike bowen and indicating that
we are we're our mass supply our e-95
respiratory supply was
was completely decimated and he said
we're in deep i pushed that forward to
the highest levels i could in hhs
and got no response president trump
dismissed bright's accusations
i watched him and he looks like an angry
disgruntled employee
who frankly according to some people
didn't do a very good job
and suggested that a vaccine was not far
away
i think we're going to have a vaccine by
the end of the year
but breit said that was overly
optimistic a lot of optimism
is swirling around a 12 to 18 month time
frame
if everything goes perfectly we've never
seen everything go perfectly
hours after bright testified that there
is still no master plan
the cdc issued some long-delayed
guidance for reopening schools and
businesses
but cbs news has learned it's a less
detailed version of an earlier draft
that the white house criticized as
overly prescriptive
cbs news medical contributor dr david
agus
says the guidelines don't adequately
show states how to reopen
safely these guidelines are watered down
they went from
what is reported to be a 63-page
document to you
you know know digit page set of simple
guidelines
and the the details on how to do and how
to enact things were just taken out
as dr aegis just mentioned that 63-page
document was boiled down into
these six single page memos covering
topics like
workplace restaurants and schools but
the guidance is very general in many
cases the same with broad suggestions
like
promote good hygiene and have a plan if
employees get sick
a senior administration official tells
cbs news americans
do not have the time to read 63 pages
and the cdc says they will publish more
guidance in the coming days
and weeks anthony
we just